[Music]
so my husband has seemed to have a
change of values over the past couple
years what are one or two that are
driving you like scaring you making you
uncomfortable we both grow up in the
same religion he still somewhat believes
but he also likes to say that I've been
[Music]
brainwashed what's going on this is John
with the Dr John deloney show a show
about your marriage your kids your
emotional health your mental health
whatever you got going on in the
world holidays are coming up you're just
have survived or maybe you didn't
survive Thanksgiving and we're right
into Christmas I saw something recently
man Christmas and Thanksgiving should be
six months apart cuz we just need to
recover here we are not to mention
political mess drama just tons of
heartbreak going on overseas it's just
one thing thing after
another and then there's you sitting at
home sitting on the couch next to
somebody that you're married to feeling
6 Ines apart but 6,000 miles away your
kids struggling schools a mess your
mental health whatever is going on in
your life everybody's there everybody's
there here's my promise on this show
I'll sit with you this show is real
people going through real challenges in
real time I'll sit with you and we will
figure out what we're going do
next I care about you I care about
people and I got a vested interest in
this because I got two little kids man
they're not little anymore I got two
young kids and you all the listeners of
this show the people who join me on the
show y'all are building the world that
they're going to have it so I want us to
all get it right and what we're doing is
not working so let's try to do something
new if you want to be on the show give
me a buzz at 1 1844 693
3291 it's 1 1844 693 3291 or go to John
dooney.com
ask and it's not too late they may all
be sold out by now but it's worth
getting on there and checking them out
questions for humans the Christmas
edition we sold all the way out of them
last year um we're recording this in the
middle of November and they just told me
where there's no way that they're still
around by the time Christmas comes
around but it may there may be still be
some left and Kelly let's run through a
few questions questions for humans nice
all right first
you just weren't very believable just
then nice nice and when do you really
and truly feel like it's Christmas time
man when when we put our live Christmas
tree up in the house and I'm a I have a
weird thing I I have we all have to be a
part of decorating it everybody's got to
be there we got to put on weird music
and we all have to do it and go through
the box and it' be so much easier if
just one person just knocked it out and
if you're like us we have to talk about
each ornament and remember when they got
this and then blah blah blah and you and
I were talking the other day like all
the kids put all the ornaments in like
the same 6 in spot uhuh and then I fix
it after everybody goes to bed we all
have to be a part of it and that's after
that I feel like it is Christmas
Christmas Christmas yeah that's a good
one what about you um honestly ours for
me it's our when you see me yes that
feels like Christmas every day it's just
Christmas in my heart you don't have a
heart but in that in your chest cavity
in my chest cavity where should be um no
my the thing for me is our Church's
choir concert it's such a big moment for
us every year you would um it's just it
is it's it's like Three Amigos when
they're like I would buy cars I would do
this I would build an orphanage my
husband sings in the choir uh and our um
our choir is is something to be hold I
mean I go to a big church so there's a
lot of it and it's just always a
fantastic production but they do it
simply it's not like Vegas you know it's
beautiful and um we didn't get to go
last year because we were at my mother's
service and so it felt really weird it
was like a marker that didn't happen and
so we're looking forward to it this year
it feels a lot like there's going to be
a peruma pom pom slid in there at that
concert um sometimes there actually one
year they had like a high school drum
corp so sometimes there is I do I I will
say I get up and go to the bathroom if
they play Mary did you know because she
knew she knew she knew the angel told
her I won't get on that Soap Box and if
there was Little Drummer Boy I would
have to just leave see I like little
drummer boy well that's CU you have
diagnos diagnosable mental illness all
right let's go to the next
one what Christmas movie gets way too
much hype this is a this is a
potentially Jimmy Jimmy It's a Wonderful
Life I hate that movie not a great movie
no I don't hate it I don't like it
though we don't watch it not a good
movie the sentiment great hey if you
weren't here other people people might
not have as much joy it's kind of a
horror movie or my wife might have found
some way wealthier way better looking
guy in her life would be incredible I
don't know yeah I'm not a fan yeah not a
fan not a fan what's an underrated
Christmas
movie Jenna Muppet Christmas
Carol I love the Muppet Christmas we
both love the Muppet Christmas Carol
we've both come across some people who
have don't like Muppets at all so they
don't like that I you know why cuz
they're they're sociopath right exactly
Muppet Christmas Carol is is awesome
it's the best Nightmare Before Christmas
is my number one of all time um there's
one on Netflix and that a lot of people
may not know about it's called Jingle
jangle and it's if you liked the
greatest showman you'll love it I know
the title's stupid but if you like the
greatest showman you'll love it because
it's the same choreographer same music
same costuming but it's a really great
uh Forest Whitakers in it it's just this
like you watch it you're like I feel
really good oh I know that movie yeah
it's a great Christmas movie but when
you say the words jingle jingle well I
just imagine you running through like
like a park with meth in your pocket
that just feels like jingle jangle like
that's just the that's the thought I
have you what's wrong with you I don't
know let's go out to Virginia and talk
to the
Mt what's up Matt how we
doing hey Dr John uh thanks for taking
my call man pretty uh pretty excited
pretty nervous oh don't be nervous I'm
excited but don't be nervous all right
so what's up dude no I'm I'm nervous
because my girlfriend's going to listen
to this because she's the reason that uh
I'm listen listen to you and called
you all right she use your words
carefully she use your words carefully
what's up she knows about it so I'll
jump to the question and then Circle
back
um it's because of a call that you took
last week about the guy who had wanted
more communication and I identified with
him a lot and you told her to run so my
question is uh am I am I that guy uh
also am I asking too much uh and if so
you know how do I make make peace with
uh the relationship where our
communication styles are so different
and I don't get as much as I want and
there's lots of background yeah so you
could do a 10p part series on us man you
would love it oh man I appreciate your
call um so hey Kelly can you fill me in
on that um I don't we we Matt we record
these sometimes up to a month apart so I
don't remember that call um I think it
was the one who the that he's talking
about is the guy the woman called in and
her if she didn't text her boyfriend
first thing in the morning all
communication all day long and you know
if if she didn't text by 9
he okay okay so moving the gold post you
better run girl that kind of one yes
okay so you're that that guy sounds like
you right a little bit we diverge um in
some areas but yeah the the feelings of
being an afterthought I mean I don't
need I don't need calls every 10 seconds
or anything crazy and I don't need
detailed list of what she does but I do
feel like there's such a huge gap in our
communication and I have also moved the
goalpost but um to use the football
analogy I moved them closer I don't ask
for 10 yards for a touchdown I just want
her to hike the damn ball I'll give her
a touchdown well and I feel like every
go ahead oh I said I feel like every
time I I I ask for less and less because
she says she can't give more I I I ask
for less and less and she still says
nope too much nope too much nope too
much and it's tough because it's it's I
don't want be that guy who's driving her
away and making her want to run but I
just I love this woman with all my heart
and I just want to I just love talking
to her and hearing from her and that
sort of thing so it sounds like she's
moving the goalpost back so or she's
moving the goalpost too let me put it
that way
um Let me let me try to ask the question
this way sure
um well let me let you ask your question
what's your question
so is it's if I'm asking too much if I'm
if I am being overbearing um you know we
don't we're both Divorced with kids live
a town apart and she has her kids week
on week off I've got mine maybe a third
of the time and during those sometimes
seven to 10 days that we don't see each
other I really crave that connection at
least through the telephone because we
don't get to physically see each other
much um and that's when it really feels
like I I feel like an afterthought she
she even said extraneous uh at one point
you know and uh it was tough I mean I
used the word first to be very fair but
she's like yeah you do feel extraneous
during those times when I've just got
the kids and I'm dealing with them and
and yeah I don't have time for you so
what what it's tough yeah I mean no I
don't think that's I don't you don't
sound like that other guy at all to me
now maybe you listened and felt that way
but I don't I don't hear that at all um
why when she has her kids do yall not
see each
other um so we we used to um heck we
even we were even engaged for two weeks
a couple months ago she's got um a
daughter who's 14 who's doing the
classic I hate mom because I'm a
teenager I want to kill myself when I'm
around you sort of thing I mean that's
not really the classic seem like she's
got a lot of strugg struggles maybe not
classic but there's that there's that
angst between Mom and teenage daughter
and then it's to the point where she was
making suicidal ideations and even
cutting and it occurred right after our
engagement because she's like I don't
want you guys to be engaged I don't I
don't I don't want a new life um and so
my girlfriend called off the engagement
um after a couple of weeks because of
that not only that there's a Ramy
Solutions connection I had a little more
dep than she realized and she's like
Wella step back you know and I'm working
we're working on that I'm on step two
but um what do you mean like she
realized you you finally came clean
about you owe a whole bunch of money and
debt right she knew about she knew about
student loans uh from law school um and
a little credit card debt she knew that
my The Firm that I'm I'm about to leave
has been really financially tough on me
and I didn't really disclose how tough
it had been so after the engagement I
said I gave her a spreadsheet and said
here I am and she's like who that's more
than I expected um but we we worked a
plan you know to to to do it together
she's a financial Wiz she's got I mean
she's just
phenomenal um and I'm struggling and
that coupled with the daughter sort of I
shouldn't going off the deep Bend but
the stress with her daughter she's like
this is too much we need to step back so
that's why I don't get to come around
that often anymore because it seems to
stress out her daughter now her daughter
is living with her her
ex-husband um now more full-time because
of the stress so I may be invited around
a little bit more but that hasn't
happened yet in the last month so it's
It's just tough yeah
um man I'm just going to I'm just going
to give it to you straight is that cool
yeah please I think these communication
challenges and the I'm all in but wait
col let's let's take a breather let me
see the
spreadsheet all of this feels like
theater to a much bigger issue in your
relationship
together
it feels like they're y'all are not
nearly as close as you want to
be yeah and y'all are not nearly as far
apart as she would feel
safe and so what happens is it's almost
like uh two magnets that are turned the
wrong way y'all just push each other
away so hard pursuer distancer kind of
dynamic yeah it just becomes a you've
heard me say it on the show it becomes a
dance where yeah I'm starving I can't
breathe I can't breathe I can't breathe
and you're my oxygen and then the I
can't breathe I can't breathe you're
smothering
me and she's using you as as an excuse
to um she's using distance from you as
an
excuse to make herself her alarm Bells
not ring off the hook because she
probably went through a gnarly divorce
that was a mess and she has a daughter
that's chaotic that's dude you can't you
can't let you can't let a teenager
dictate your life they they that young
girl cannot handle the power of
determining her mom's dating
relationships that's too much that's too
much power to give to a child she can't
carry that weight well you hit the nail
on the head with the terrible divorce uh
her ex-husband married the Paramore the
the mistress that caused the divorce and
moved her in right away and I and I we
we suspect that that has something to do
with the um resistance to our
relationship you know interloper but at
the same
time um
you're your financial insecurity your
professional insecurity you work in a
very very difficult job nobody calls an
attorney because you're having a great
day right so you enter into people's
pain every day of your life as
um uh as a way of being and so you've
identified her your body's identif F her
as your as a cup of water as your oxygen
and when you don't get it man use tax
more where are you why aren't you me am
I just afterthought and it's that it's
that internal can't breathe can't
breathe can't breathe like when you're
underwater a little bit too long and
then the kid won't get off of you and
all of a sudden your body goes to full
right and it just gets to that weird
dance that's that's it 100% that's
that's what it feels like it's yeah it's
a craving yeah yeah yeah and so for me
um I think the conversation has to be
way way beneath communication Style by
the way that language is so frustrating
for me not to you I'm I'm really
grateful that y'all are identifying I
communicate this way I communicate that
way it's super frustrating to me that
those type of simp overly simplistic
models are placed in the world because
they give people a relational out what
do I mean by that well my love language
is touch well my love language is nice
is affirmations and we just aren't
compatible and I just want to yell from
the rooftops that's so stupid there's
nothing empirical about any of that all
of that changes over time and if my w if
I'm in tune with my wife I know that she
likes to be hugged when she's when she's
hurting and if she's in tune with me she
knows that I like it when she puts her
hand on the back of my neck and says hey
I'm proud of you like it we don't have
to devolve into this I don't do that
kind of love language my I do what my
partner needs and vice versa and so I if
youall have different communication
Styles out of the gate great I don't
really care what does she need and what
do you need right if my wife needs
shifted over time that's that's the
thing it always always moves right
what's important is that every month you
say hey D I'm getting ready it's getting
super stressful at work and like just a
quick hello in the morning abs like it
changes the whole whole nature of my
day would you would you love me enough
to say hello and she'd be like yeah I
got that and if she can't do that then
your relationship has much bigger issues
in it or if she says
Hey dealing with my daughter in the
morning is so
difficult and every morning I wake up in
a panic that she's even still alive or
that there's blood on the sheets again
and like just the thought of having a
chore to do which is I got to make sure
I call him back three times can I call
you when I get to work and you'd be like
yeah absolutely babe that'd be awesome
but until y'all have that level of
conversation um it's just going to be
this pingpong match of well you did this
well you didn't do this and it just
becomes theater for the deeper issues
here
yeah it sounds and by the way the
scariest thing for somebody who went
through a bad
divorce who is scanning the environment
24/7 365 for am I safe am I safe am I
safe is finding out that the person that
they almost went all in on didn't tell
them the full
truth yeah no I I I know that I I was
definitely wrong um that's a huge regret
yeah yeah have you have you said that in
that
way I I don't know I know I've
apologized and said I'm sorry I didn't
tell you this earlier um I think it's
deeper than that I failed you
yeah no I did as 100% ACC awesome that's
awesome and I failed in my I failed in
my last marriage you know it was my
fault so it's like in what way oh I
stepped out on the marriage I I wasn't I
wasn't honest with my ex-wife that I was
hurting and feeling unloved and feeling
uh worthless and devalued and I found
somebody that made me feel good for a
little while and uh sure I just don't
want I don't want to make those mistakes
because like this woman is the light of
my life and and I think when she said it
before when our Highs are high they are
they're they're they're to the Moon in
back because we just you know we're both
we both have similar jobs like she's
active duty military I'm Reserve now but
um you know we've got these we have so
much common ground and just love food
and I love to cook and she loves to eat
and I do to you know just it's so much
is so good it's intense it's I mean we
both said that we fell in love the
minute we walked into the coffee shop
the first time we met you know and
that's probably damn accurate and it's
it's been wonderful but those lows are
just you know use that analogy of like
the love tank just rins and I just you
know so let me ask you a hard question
sure you've done some dumb things I have
too we all have yeah but you've painted
me a pretty clear picture of a guy that
doesn't like himself
why I was afraid you're going to ask me
that question because I haven't come up
with the answer I've been in therapy for
two years trying to figure it
out and and I can't it's it's hard I
mean you know I had loving parents
nuclear family uh wonderful Christian
household um great career in the Marines
for you know 25 years you know some of
it active duty and um have accomplished
a lot became an attorney like I mean
just you know a lot of things that I'm
like this is awesome I've finally done
it all but that but that's a guy that's
been that's been running from Hill to
Hill saying oh I have peace on that hill
and then you get to that hill and you're
like well damn it I went with me there's
piece over on that hill and then you
start running and you and dude nobody
can stop you you can do anything if you
get out of active duty military after 25
years and you go to law school with all
those kids and you get out and start
practi like no one can stop you you can
do whatever you
want but that sounds like a guy that's
running from
himself yeah and if you if you expect
any woman to fill that or that doomed
statement that Tom Cruz like whispered
across the room like if you're waiting
for somebody to complete you dude that
they're ultimately not going to be able
to carry that
weight I'm afraid I'm afraid that's what
I'm putting on her I want her to
compliment me not complete me and I'm
afraid
I'm the only way only way that can
happen that's a beautiful sentiment the
only way that can happen is if you
recognize that your oxygen comes from
within your chest not from
her I don't like my oxygen I know but
I'm telling you as an outsider it looks
good I appreciate that so what if this
what if instead of going to a therapist
and just talking and talking and talking
and talking what if you
begin practicing liking
yourself and that sounds so cheesy I'm
going tell you something that my
counselor made me do okay okay and it
melted
me and I'm tired today and so I'm
probably G to get choked up talking
about it so she called me out once I may
I don't know if I've talked about on the
show or not but we we've she called me
out
once and she said oh my she's an oracle
right she said oh my gosh you don't like
you and and I was like yes I do like no
you don't I was like I
do and she said say it say the words I
love this guy and I started laughing I
was like I'm not saying that and she
goes say it and she goes just say it say
it to me I love this guy you know she
made me make a fist and put it in my
chest and say I love this guy ultimately
I couldn't do it yeah it was the
strangest outof body experience
dude I couldn't do it and she goes there
it is she goes none of the rest of the
stuff gets better none of the rest of
the stuff
heals until you're okay with you because
if you're not okay with you everybody
feels you trying to get something from
them and some people want that but that
always ends up in an unhealthy Dynamic
other people like my daughter or your
girlfriend SL fianceg girlfriend their
bodies sense it and they feel like
they're going to get dragged underwater
by two big guys like us and so they bolt
they bail they back
up yeah I don't want that I want her
to yeah I I want to
love Yeah God I can't even say it yeah
so exactly so here's your homework and
I'm it's gonna be as cheat dude I expect
people listening to go is that a 200b
Texan talking to a former Marine telling
him to put his fist in his chest and
look in his bathroom mirror and say I
love this guy five to 10 times a day yes
that's what's happening right right
now but I want you to do it and listen
when you say it I want you to
intentionally relax and drop your
shoulders down because you can probably
Flex through it that's what you've been
doing your whole life you Flex through
law school you Flex through basic you
Flex through all your promotions you
Flex through all of it that's what you
could
do but you can't Flex through making
some woman feel safe especially someone
who's already just been burnt to Ash
that has to come from the inside out the
only way that happens is if you
admit I got to practice like being okay
with
me I can't expect somebody to carry
that I'm just going to tell you on this
side of
it it's healed my relationship with my
daughter it's healed my relationship
with my son it's healed my relationship
with my wife it's made me a general
better person to be around a safer
person to be around cuz I'm not grabbing
every person in my life and saying Hold
Me Up Hold Me Up Hold Me Up Hold Me Up
Hold Me Up hold me up I'm able to walk
into a room safe whole on my own two
feet and look around and say how can I
love each and every one of you and hey
here's what I need to be loved guys I'm
going put that out there that's a
totally different Dynamic so starting
today you to put your chest in your hand
and look in the mirror and say the words
I love this guy and I want you to do
that every day for the next 30
days and then tell your wife or tell
your fiance maybe your wife one day
girlfriend I've been expecting you to
hold me up and I'm
sorry and whenever somebody can't hold
me up I get nervous and then I get
clingy and then I go looking for I start
hiding things I I keep secrets no more
no more
no
more hang on the line brother I'm going
to send you a copy of building a
unanxious life as my gift to you read
that dude and it'll give you a road
map from point A to point B I'm start
living into these things as I
practice learning to be okay with
myself and it's good to go to counseling
dude go talk to somebody but let's just
startop stop the loop the loop the loop
let's start really honing in I love this
guy this guy safe and this guy can do
hard stuff this guy can take care of
people and this guy's okay saying what
he needs out
loud do you love me
too and then dude we'll deal with the
we'll deal with the communication stuff
on the back
end let's start at the route I'm proud
of you brother proud of you and tell the
truth Matt tell the truth we'll be right
back hey deloney here look people always
say the holidays are The Most Wonderful
Time of the Year and for some of us the
holidays are great but they're Mayhem
for all of us you're probably traveling
all over the place talking to family
members you didn't ask for by the way
shopping GH trying to make it to all the
parties and no one will turn off the
Christmas music but inside the chaos
remember you still have a choice the
choice to take care of yourself taking
care of yourself begins with a good
night's sleep and I believe good sleep
starts with an amazing mattress that's
why my family sleeps on dreamcloud
dreamcloud mattresses have a combination
of gel memory foam and coil technology
that keeps you comfortable all night and
right now dreamcloud is running their
biggest offer ever exclusively for our
listeners 40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 in savings by using promo
code John deloney visit dreamcloud sleep
and enter promo code John deloney to get
your new mattress and the rest your body
needs that's dream clouds sleep.com with
code John
deloney all right we're back let's go
out to Salt Lake City and talk to
Janelle what's up
Janelle hey I'm good can you hear me I
can how are you okay I am very nervous I
cannot believe that I'm actually talking
to you I can't believe I'm talking to
you I am so grateful and hope that you
can give me words of wisdom today I will
do my best what's
up so my question is how do you live
with someone that has BP or borderline
personality disorder and the guilt that
comes along with that and so the
background is um my son who is in adult
he's
23 the precipitating uh thing is
that we he's had
several I I wouldn't say
suicide attempts necessarily but
definitely very strong threats of
suicide um and then this last month he
was pulled over um for having um an
equipment malfunction on his car but
also had an open container in the
car and refused to talk to the police
and the car is registered in my
husband's name so they called
him and said look you know uh we're have
your son pulled over you know can you
get him to talk to us and anyway it was
a long drawn out event night he ended up
deciding to go to a hospital on a
72-hour hold instead of going to
jail and um
so long story short he there were no
beds anywhere in the state of Utah for
him to go to an inpatient place so I had
to go and pick him up and get him out
but I had told him you cannot live with
us anymore because drinking and driving
was one of our hard stop you cannot do
this while you live
here and so
um then he left and he came home for one
night left and went to be with someone
who lives out of state a friend and came
back the week
later in the
meantime I called his
therapist which is the first time I've
ever done that I've never had any
contact with his therapist ever but I
was like okay he's in a bad situation in
a bad spot um threatening suicide again
left the
state and his therapist kind of LED with
well people with borderline personality
disorder this is a you know suicidal
threats and stuff are common and I just
went
what like it was
so
it was such a validation of everything
that we've dealt with with him over the
last however many years wait hold on the
therapist gave you your son's
diagnostic yes only because like he told
me initially first you need to call back
and leave your message I will listen to
your message and if I have questions I
will call you back gotcha okay so I said
okay so I called and left message and
told him what was going on and he called
back and he said because this is a
safety issue because he's threatening
suicide okay and now you know you're not
in contact with him and you don't know
where he is this is the only reason that
I can talk to you okay all right I want
let's pause let's pause here for a
second I want to do this um I want to
take a second or a minute or two if
that's okay and teach for just a second
okay to everybody listening borderline
personality disorder you heard me
exhale you heard mom go I knew
it here's what borderline personality
disorder is by the way I love love these
folks
and man I'm a pretty differentiated guy
and so if you walk away from me that's
fine um and my kids don't have it or
they haven't been diagnosed with it yet
um here's borderline personality
disorder your feelings feel like
fire and so they experience the world
differently than other people so were
you a listener casual listener you get
mad they get
enraged you like somebody you meet them
at a at a bar and you like them you meet
them at church and you like
them their body is a wash in love I love
them and I love them forever and ever
amen
until they're four minutes late and then
I hate them they're the worst I destroy
them right and so there's this obsession
with abandonment and it's often imagined
it's often not real like four minutes
late right I had I I was going to the
bathroom and I came out and by the time
you get there that annoyance like let's
say someone's late 5 minutes late to a
date I can feel
it and then when I see them and I go
where were you and they go oh I had to
go run to the bathroom I go okay often
somebody with borderline personality
sort of can't come back when that train
leaves the station one way or the other
it is gone best ever worst ever there is
no middle
ground and in counselors we know when
somebody comes in and says hey I've seen
six counselors you're the greatest
counselor of all time you're the only
one that has ever got
me counselors go uhoh right cuz here
we're going to be on the other side and
very very impulsive so here's a here's a
picture I want to paint for somebody who
doesn't know what this is imagine you're
walking through the woods on a hike and
you're surrounded all of a sudden bees
are all over your arms and legs and
they're stinging you all over you would
roll run flop scream jump in a lake
cover yourself with leaves you do
whatever you could to get these bees off
of you if somebody was to be 200 yards
from you and just see you acting they
would think oh no this person's bananas
b an n but to you it makes perfect sense
you're getting stung by bees right so if
you've got borderline personality
disorder one of the strong
characteristics is highly impulsive and
often irres irresponsible Behavior so
when your body when your feelings feel
like
fire you go sleep with four people over
a two-day period you go you don't drink
you
drink right y you don't tell somebody
hey I I can't talk to you
today you burn them to the ground or I
feel like I can't get a hold of Mom I'm
just going to tell Mom I'm I'm thinking
about hurting myself or what a classic
line is I'm having dark dark thoughts
and then everybody comes back right it's
this intensity this paranoia an actual
fear of something that folks around them
often can't even see or experience very
black or white they call it splitting it
is this or this period right either or
not both and so am I hitting am I that
that's borderline personality disorder
in a nutshell and the reason I love
completely you completely put my son in
that nutshell Okay the reason I love
them is they experience the world in
such a
multicolorful way a powerful way they I
I'm I'm jealous of how joyful they can
be and here's what's super frustrating
they're often brilliant brilliant
brilliant and when they tell
me I hate you I'm able to walk away and
be like well my wife loves me and my
kids mostly do so I'm my dogs like me so
um that's hard when you're a mom right
oh my gosh mom guilt is the worst thing
on the face of the planet that's right
and you have probably done the terrible
thing which is Google borderline
personality disorder and somewhere
they've it said it's it's got a strong
genetic link and you've gone oh I did
this to him
well yes but the other part of that also
is everything that I've read is saying
that it's a lot of it almost every case
is trauma
in I'm
like to my knowledge there has been no
abuse to my knowledge like we have a
really tight close family and I just
kind of
go okay how is there
trauma for him and did I cause it and
what so let me tell you let me tell you
the problem let me tell you the the
scary thing about the track you're on
and then please just stop the train
where it is okay number one I was with
my wife for 25 years and there were some
things I didn't tell her about what I
experienced as a kid yeah just because
you're tight doesn't mean you don't you
know right the second thing is that
question that you start asking we're a
tight-nit family and what about this all
if you're not careful ends up in what
about
me what did I
do right and his pain and his experience
of the
world somehow becomes your
issue it somehow becomes what about what
about me and with the B someone
struggles with borderline it can never
it can never loop back that
way yeah I mean it's like seriously he
has been this way his as far as I I mean
I his mom and I gave birth to him as far
as I know and have can look back at his
entire life he has been like
this like his siblings would get mad
because I would just be like hey look
he's just different like he feels things
intensely so when he's mad he's pissed
yeah and when he's happy he's over the
moon happy and I so I've always his
whole life explained him that way to
people
right and so I don't know I'm like so
now that he is no longer living with
us we went down
today mostly my husband because I
couldn't do it because I cried the whole
time okay to the room that he was
staying in and I
said I just feel like I'm betraying him
by packing up his stuff in your in your
house in my house and my husband
said you know he has to start learning
the consequences of his adult choices
and I'm like I know but as a mom I
cannot like it's
so hard the greatest gift you can give
him is both I see
you and I believe
you and here are my
boundaries it's the greatest gift you
can give feel so guilty as a mom setting
boundaries know and that's that's
a those feelings you
feel you're asking him who gets so
enraged and he does like it's scary I
listen listen to me listen to me he gets
so enraged and he has figured out
something that that numbs that rage
alcohol yep and you're asking him when
you feel enraged don't go drive we have
to develop some different
behaviors right I'm asking you the same
thing your guilt and you're allowing him
to just keep doing whatever he wants to
do because you feel guilty hasn't worked
right right let's try something
else the greatest gift you can give him
is I love you I believe you that your
skin is on fire
you cannot bring cocaine into my
house I believe you that you are in
pain if you make a threat on your life I
will call the police 100% of the time
every time and that's not going to be
your Avenue to me that's going to be
your Avenue to a 72-hour
hold right an Avenue to me is you
walking in the front door and letting me
hold my
baby I don't care how old you are right
but if you act only as a response to the
guilt you feel nothing
changes yeah and by the way he has to go
get DBT dialectical behavior therapy he
has to choose that that's the path for
him okay and you can't do that for
him so what do I do in the future
because I can just see this cycling
around again that he's going to lose his
place where he's staying right now and
say I don't have any place to live can I
come home and I'm like how do you look I
know logically that I can say no you
can't but how do you emotionally the
emotional side my heart says how do you
tell your kid I'm sorry you can't come
live here you
grieve yeah you allow yourself to feel
it and in the same way you would tell
him hey hey hey hey
hey I know you are so angry about being
abandoned and you're about to go home
with those four women please don't this
will
pass I'll tell you the same
thing everything in your body will
scream at you let him come home let him
come home let him come
home that will
pass okay or you can come home
here are the
stipulations here are the
boundaries and be honest I've not held
these in the past and I learning that I
have not done you any
favors or you can come home first time
but you will enroll in
DBT and I would like to if you feel safe
I would like to um I would like you to
sign that I can have a conversation with
your counselor so I can see how you're
doing if you don't go right I hear you
that it's scary I hear you that it makes
you feel powerless
and here's the truth the truth is you
can't live here unless you are actively
pursuing
care yep and I will tell you Mom
borderline personality disorder has a
high rate of success for treatment and
it is hell and it's
long because you basically have to learn
inside my body that what my body feels
in any given moment is not the
truth and that's just tough to to
reimagine I mean re-experience life
right
right that's hard hard hard he's got
he's got a tall Order ahead of him and
he can do
it yeah I'm just it's it was so
interesting because I felt like a th000
PB weight lifted off me when I finally
heard that mhm I was like I've been
throwing darts at a wall and now I
actually have a Target except here's the
problem here's the problem mom you don't
have a Target he
does right right you have been solving
his problems his whole life and you
can't solve this
one you're
right but I feel like at least it gives
it an identity and a name oh yeah we
named the dragon on this one like oh my
gosh I'm not crazy nope because you know
he goes into his rages and telling me
how stupid and dumb I am and you know
what I mean like you just feel like an
idiot but hold on that's when you stop
and say I'm gonna stop
you I hear you that you're very mad I
believe
you you are not allowed to be
disrespectful in my house to me or your
father period so if you choose to be
disrespectful you're choosing to leave
oh my gosh are you in that I'm telling
I'm gonna stop you right there this is
your last
shot you're choosing to
leave I prefer you to stay I want you
here and by the way that interaction is
not going to solve this he's got to go
get very directed
therapy and it's hard it's hard he's got
to learn tolerance for that fire feeling
that he body feels like it's on fire but
it's actually not yeah and then he's got
to learn some new
behaviors in place of the ones that are
impulsive and ultimately destructive got
to retrain his body as to what feels
normal that's tough tough tough
tough so I can just continue to tell him
that I love him and I support him and
all day long I love you yeah that's one
of the most important things I see you I
see you and here's the truth can't do
that or you cannot live here I would be
honored if you would have dinner with me
every Wednesday night and lunch with me
every Sunday
afternoon right forget you if you're not
going to let me live here I don't want
anything to do with you I hate that I
hear you and I know you're mad I hear
it but you can't live here but I would
really love it if I could buy you dinner
on Wednesdays and Sundays to catch up
see how you're
doing right and if you fulfill program
ABC and D I'd love to figure out helping
you get an apartment or helping you move
back in or I'd love to go to therapy
with
you see what I'm saying we're not
abandoning him which is his worst
nightmare right we are saying I'll walk
alongside you but he doesn't get to
dictate his his volatility doesn't get
to dictate this relationship his stable
mother and father
do and over time hopefully that is
something he can anchor into
finally Because He Lives an
anchorless life and he's just whipped
around by feelings and by the way for
those of you like wondering like oh is
that real borderline personality dis
disorder is very very real and the
feelings the intensity is very
real I've seen it it is
wow deep compassion for folks who
struggle that and my goodness there some
of my favorite people on the
planet but again I don't have one that's
a child so I can walk out of a room be
like hey dude I'm I'm not going to do
this but I love you and when you're
ready to to hang out I would love to one
of my favorite
people I've had students over the years
that were
brilliant and hilarious and so fun and
woo when things got sideways like it was
tough very very tough then deep shame
and all of it loop back here's what I'm
saying be
present let them know you see them and
you hear them
and then you got to hold firm on the
boundaries and it sounds like Mom it
would be good for you to go talk to
somebody too to have somebody walk
alongside
you give you some tips and some support
and some tools on how to love somebody
be in relationship with somebody that
struggles with borderline personality
disorder it's very very
hard and let's set down the bricks of
guilt and what did I do what about me
let's let's let's let's don't do that
let's make it about kind of home do I
want to have what are the boundaries I
want to build and how can I love and
support
him cuz my guest is Mom you didn't do
anything
[Music]
wrong the truth is you got a hurting son
Let's head that way I'm grateful for you
Janelle thank you so so much for the
call we'll be right
back hey good folks delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time those become healthy
habits they almost become automatic like
choosing to slow down and make time for
a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with my daily practice is hallow hallow
is the number one Prayer app in the
world and they're giving you three free
months to get started that's three
months for free to prioritize your
mental and spiritual health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music through guided prayers
meditation and more and by the way
hallow isn't just Catholic you can
tailor the content towards your faith
tradition or if you don't have a faith
tradition it's a great place to start
from scripture readings to prayers to
journaling Hall makes it easy to
practice mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember Hall is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can established in 90 days go to
hall.com dealone today to start your
free trial just follow the simple
prompts at hall.com
dealone for 90 days
free all right we're back let's go out
to proo Utah and talk to Dear Marie
what's up
Marie hey how's it going we're partying
what's up what are you up
to oh thanks for taking my call I
appreciate it of course what's happening
um so my husband has seemed to have a
change of I don't know if you'd call him
values but like I guess values over the
past couple years um and I'm just I
don't know how to like respect him and
his views and still hold true to what's
important to
me
yikes so give me some insight what do he
what do
he I mean this sounds like you are at
the edge here here like what is what has
he changed his values on oh I feel
like I mean it's like little things
like um I'm a pretty conservative person
and so like swearing has never been like
an awesome thing for me and so it's
little like I know a lot of
conservatives just swear like like
Sailors you you don't like swearing and
he didn't and now he does and now he
does and then but then it escalates to
the way we're parenting four kids
together and so then it's like he thinks
it's completely fine for a six-year-old
to
watch like PG-13 movies or things that I
feel like are too violent or things like
that and he thinks it's fine and so like
it's just there's a wide range of things
what are one or two that are driving you
like scaring you making you
uncomfortable
um well I think
um we both grew up in the same religion
and now he's
having
um I he's he still somewhat believes but
he also likes to say that I've been
brainwashed Okay and like the way he
speaks about it to
me
um but yeah I just I he feel I don't
know I don't know he's he says he's
always been an angry person
and for a long time he's tried to
like not be that way but I kind of
almost feel like he's slipping into well
this is just me and it's okay and I
almost kind of like it and so I think
that's one of the things that are
scaring me the
most is he becoming
abusive um I wouldn't say physically but
like there are
like emotionally some stuff that's
happening that I don't love give me an
example of
it um he he curses like a sailor right
and and
so before it was always um he would do
it occasionally like if he were to hurt
himself working or doing something right
um and then it changed to instead of
calling inanimate objects those names he
turned it on to me and so now I'm
getting called those things have you
have you said you will not curse at me
in my
home yeah I've tried what does he what
does he say to
that he I he almost kind of takes it as
a
challenge like well what are you going
to do about
it I have something in my guts Marie
that tells me there's something deeper
here because I I'll just be honest I've
had periods of my marriage of 21
years when I completely walked away from
my childhood Faith walked away
completely my wife has had Ser Seasons
when what she believes now is radically
different from what she believed when
she was
married yeah and both of us have loved
being a steady partner for the other
person while they're reconsidering
things learning new things leaning on
doubt leaning on conviction all those
things
MH but at no point has it ever turned to
me verse
you right and that's what I don't that's
what I don't love about the situation
and like I know that sometimes I haven't
handled things perfectly but I still
just feel like there's hold on if you
ask your husband do not swear at me
and he then fires up a bunch of swear
words and says whatat are you going to
do about
it that's a power
Flex
right and that rarely happens in a
vacuum yeah that's a dude that looks
down on his wife with disdain she is
beneath him she's not a person to be
respected I wouldn't do that to a I I
swear too much okay like I run my mouth
too much but also I try my best to be
respectful yeah and even when Kell's
like hey can you just chill on the
diarrhea jokes yeah absolutely I mean
depending on where we
are right you see what I'm saying it's
not like oh you wait now just that's
just dumb it's just
disrespectful right and so that's
contempt that is a relationship that's
be being held together by string and
duct
tape
right what's the deeper issue
here is he seeing somebody
else no
no no I mean we we definitely have don't
have enough time to get to all the
issues but no there's other things going
on and okay I I don't know so how can I
help I just I want to know how to
to not feel like we're fighting about
everything like I feel like our views
are so opposite on most things and I
just I want views are not the problem
views are not the
problem it's the respect by which you
treat each
other that's the
problem
I've got very few of my closest friends
share my specific faith in the way that
I believe
it yeah very very few of my friends
follow up and down with my political
beliefs very few if
any ideological
beliefs beliefs about love and care and
marriage very very few
but the way we engage each other and the
way I respect them and the way they
respect me guides
everything right and I think that's a
great fallacy of the culture we live in
now which is you have to believe every
single thing I do exactly the way I
believe it and I think that's nonsense
it's not
real but we do have to be like
respectful human beings and treat each
other with
dignity otherwise we're children we're
children and so I don't think it's a
matter if you'll have different beliefs
it sounds like your husband's treating
you like
dirt and my question for you is why it
almost seems like you're giving them a
pass you're trying to make the problem
the beliefs and not
him
well I can't do anything about
him but you can flip the lights on and
call a spade a
spade ultimately here's the deal you
have to have an or what
statement when you get down to somebody
being super disrespectful or doing
things that you think hurt your kids
which if you are showing young children
violent movies you are hurting your kids
period if you're swearing at your kids
screaming and cursing at your children
or you're cursing at their mom in front
of them you're hurting your kids period
if you land
there if you're punching holes through
sheetrock I'm not hitting anybody okay
you're creating an environment where
everybody is terrified of what you're
going to do
next if every time Mom packs the kids up
and is going to church dad's sitting on
the couch making fun of Mom yelling at
mom you're so brainwashed you're such an
idiot then you have to make a
choice this is the bed I've made I'm
going to lay in
it
or here's my or what statement if you
treat me like this again or scare the
kids like this again we are going to
leave and if you don't have an or what
statement then your husband's question
Rings true what are you going to do
about
it
and that feels like it's closer to home
than you want to believe
right yeah
probably like at the very beginning of
this call you have a tone in your voice
that says you are about to walk out that
door and never turn around
once do you dream about that day some
times yeah sometimes
yeah can I tell you something you're not
a bad person for having that
thought do you have a place you could go
for a season for a couple of
days not really
you have a mom and a dad or a sister or
a cousin you could go stay with for a
while or a
girlfriend nothing
local that's fine doesn't have to be
local where are you tears coming from
are you mad at me and that's okay if you
are are you mad at him or are you is the
realization of the true reality that you
live in starting to wash over
you or maybe all three no it's just yeah
it's just it's just hard yeah because we
go in these phases where we're
fine and we're
not but are you fine are you are you
fine because you're playing
peacekeeper
probably or are you able to drop your
shoulders and make your jokes
back let me ask you this do you have a
friend a girlfriend there in town that
you could sit down and go have coffee
with and just put all this on the table
and tell the
truth
yeah would you consider doing
that I don't know there's something
about saying it out loud in the physical
presence of somebody else that
crystallizes it and makes it real and
sometimes it shakes us out of our
stuper because you spend a lot of your
life numb and a lot of time time in your
own head don't
you yeah yeah God you deserve a a
different kind of life than that
Murray you deserve to be loved and
cherished and challenged and you and
your husband never have to believe the
same things but youall do have to treat
each other with respect and you deserve
laughter and r unctious sex even though
you have four kids for God's sake you
like you are worth all that fun building
things planning for things having people
over your worth all
that and it just feels like you have
stucked like stuffed you so far
down in a in a sock just to keep the
peace inside your own
home
is that like my only option
like de out an
ultimatum I don't think that's going to
go over well of course it's
not it's not supposed to go over well
supposed to keep you safe and
whole
if you tell me that my first thought
would always be we're going to get out
of the house change the environment and
go
somewhere preferably over a meal we can
go slow and
talk and you for the first time can be
fully 100% honest if and only if it's
safe it's not safe then you can't do it
you're going to get
hurt either physically or emotionally or
both or if the kids are going to pay the
price for your
honesty then you have to get a therapist
you have to get a professional and you
have to walk that route but if you
haven't done that and you take your
husband out and say
hey when we got together we both
believed this we both believed this we
both believed this and over the last few
years things have changed cool people
change Ester perel says most adults have
three to four or five great loves in
their lifetime and if they work really
hard it's with the same
person I love that I'm a very very
different person than the woman than the
the woman than the man my wife
married several times over that's
awesome but if you could tell your
husband hey you've changed I've changed
our whole life is different because we
got four kids and now that we've got
four kids we're butting up against some
different beliefs I don't believe
six-year-olds should watch violent
movies it really makes me feel gross
when you curse and yell at
me makes me feel unsafe and
scared I'm just picturing myself my wife
taking me out and telling me those
things I would want to crawl under the
table I'd be so ashamed of myself and I
would commit then and there to never do
that
again but if you've done that and your
husband's respon is what are you gonna
do about
it then yeah you may be at ultimatum
stage and if you think he's going to
hurt you you think he's unsafe then you
have to get some professionals in your
area whether it's the police whether
it's a licensed therapist whether it is
some sort
of other person in your life to have
some of those conversations
with because the alternative is your
four kids growing up in a house and they
think this is what love is and this is
what safety
is this is how husbands treat wives
and let's make no mistake I read the
data are you working
full-time yeah I
am it' be really scary to be a single
mom with four kids wouldn't
it yeah for sure yeah both economically
practically professionally it's a
nightmare so I'm not saying any of this
is easy
I'm just saying I'm sick to my stomach
for you and I wish so much better for
you what are you
thinking I don't
know I tried we tried counseling for a
little bit and I just I wish we could go
back to it but things started to
get honest and he decided he didn't want
to go back
so so he chose his
comfort and he CH chose his fantasy
world
over a United healed
marriage that's what it feels like
that's not what it feels like hun that's
what it
is
and I'm so sorry for you I'm heartbroken
for
you I guess the other option here if
you're if you will convince me that
you're safe the other option here is is
for you to go see a counselor on your
own and begin to talk through I need
some new tools and some new skills so
that I can begin to defend myself stand
up for myself and ultimately make a
transition plan if that day
arises I wish with all my guts I had
better news for you Marie but if you
have a partner who says I don't care
what you say oh yeah watch this you
think that's bad watch
this oh yeah you you want to tell the
truth in a counseling session we then
screw you I'm never going
again you kids are a bunch of babies
they can watch that they're fine quit
being such a whiny brat you brainwashed
like dude you live in that
world I wish I had better news for you
man but that's a toddler you're married
to a
toddler who simply doesn't respect and
love his
wife you deserve more than
that and the path from where you are
right this second to being healed is a
treacherous and scary one make no
mistake so if you're my friend if you're
my sister if you're one of my buddies
wives call me and your well if one my
buddy's wives That's a whole different
conversation I think it starts with
getting with a girlfriend and saying I
need to tell you some hard things and
some very deep things and I Pro I know
that you withheld on this call you
didn't tell me everything and that's
fine I totally understand that but you
sit down with a girlfriend you tell her
everything here's what we're going
through and I don't know what to do next
and call a counselor and say Here's
everything I don't know what to do next
let's start at those two places and get
some people who live in your ecosystem
in your community around your family
let's get them speaking into
this but I think you deserve
more I think you deserve more and if
your husband wants to call into the show
I'd love to talk to him he won't but I'd
love to talk to thanks for the call
Murray we'll be right back
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has felt anxious or burned out or
chronically stressed at some point in my
new book building a non-anxious life
you'll learn the six daily choices that
you can make to get rid of your anxious
feelings and be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you so you
can build a more peaceful nonanxious
life get your copy today John
del. all right we are back and now it's
everybody's favorite segment am I the
problem Hey Joe do you have like some uh
mustache Camaro like jeans tucked in
your boots music that Kelly
[Music]
loves ah Kelly I just imagine when you
clean the garage this is what you listen
to you have like a marel red and you're
just like hanging out of your mouth and
you just C in the garage turn that back
up
Joe where do you think I
live and you got jean shorts on
like and your kids are like Mom and
you're like quiet
kids seriously Joe that was money all
right so what's up I'm the problem or am
I the problem yes you are listen lady
listen am I the problem let's do this go
for it all right this is from Patrick in
Georgia my wife gets upset with me when
I tell our daughter to go play or go do
something else however my daughter
constantly seeks attention from either
my wife or myself all day long after
half the day I start to feel like I
can't have a coherent thought anymore I
tell her to go play or to do something
else am I the problem or is it me or am
I the problem in saying this to her am I
being
unreasonable no your kids need to have
alone time they have boredom time they
need to have imagination time your kids
need to learn how to self soothe over
time now if you keep telling your kid go
do something go play sometimes the
landscape of possibility is so great
that can overwhelm a kid so you can say
my wife taught me this you can say you
can go play Legos or you can go color
those are your two choices I don't want
to do either of those I get that and it
feels super boring but right now I have
a project that I'm working on I need to
do this adult thing that does not
include kids so you're going to color
you're going to do this and they'll go
and they'll go color or they'll go play
Legos and their body will figure out oh
not the end of time not the end of time
but if every time you they come back you
stop everything you're like what what
what then it's kind of like uh like a
slot machine and every time they push
the button it spins and they win and
they spins and they win they've got to
learn to walk away from the slot machine
every once in a while so I don't think
you're the problem I love putting kids
in a
gambling you know analogy together I I
know I'm trying I'm trying Kelly as The
Show
Goes hey we had our best best month
again yes we did the best month best
month
ever I think we just need to sign off
and call it a day I think you hurt my
feelings sometimes in your camo jacket
just in case a deer hunting Expedition
breaks out Kelly's got up covered
hey I was about to say y'all be nice to
each other but I'm not being very nice I
know I caught myself being a little bit
of a hypocrite hey stay at school don't
do drugs I'll see you soon
bye